Welcome to the wonderful
world of Location-Aware apps.
In this lesson, you learn the basics
of using location services,
including the most parts of setting
it up for use in your app and
also how to optimize for battery use.
In the next lesson, you'll work through
a simple sample that gets some of
the useful date from location services
that go beyond latitude and longitude.
You can use the techniques that you will
learn to get cool stuff like altitude,
bearing, and speed.
You'll see more about how location
services give intelligence,
such as getting the address
at your current location.
These are the beginnings
of understanding context,
which will then give you
the ability to do cool stuff,
depending on where your
device is in the world.
Are you ready to get started?
Let's go.